la agencia europea de medicamentos dijo
que un panel de expertos se reunirá el
lunes 21 de diciembre para evaluar la
vacuna fabricada por fisher y bryant en
una reunión que se adelantó con motivo
de dictaminar la aprobación en cuestión
de días
empecemos con la vacunación tan pronto
como sea posible juntos los 27 estados
cindy ruiz con en múnich empezaremos el
mismo día como hemos ido en unidad a lo
largo de esta pandemia empecemos la
erradicación de este horrible virus
juntos y unidos united alemania francia
italia y otros 5 estados europeos
coordinarán el inicio de sus campañas de
vacunación según dijeron los ministros
de salud de los países en una
declaración conjunta este martes en
francia el portavoz del gobierno
confirmó este miércoles que la
estrategia de vacunación contra el
coronavirus en el país comenzará con un
millón de residentes de hogares de
ancianos no se politice el objetivo esta
primavera antes del verano y después de
la gente en los geriatras
cosas vacunar a las personas mayores y
vulnerables que no estén en los
geriátricos gente con comorbilidad y
esto implicará en la primavera a unos 15
millones de nuestros conciudadanos y
chipsets y por tanto todo transmisión de
estrés
por su parte alemania debería comenzar a
administrar las vacunas contra el
coronavirus entre 24 y 72 horas después
de que obtenga la aprobación y podría
comenzar tan pronto como la navidad dijo
este martes el ministro de salud y spam
con 300 millones de dosis de la vacuna
de facer bayón tec la unión europea
podría vacunar al 33 por ciento de sus
habitantes